so don't assume Oh in reflection I think
how am I allowed to drive a car this is
not a capable thing this is a Fraggle
that got stuck in a dryer I got a name
is Chris hell people you don't know now
you know your life is different now the
Teen Choice Awards happened over the
weekend
so let's judge Jean fashion choose that
one an adult woman does let's just dive
in zendaya
send damn uh what you're like a glitter
men's pajama set and it's perfect I'm
basically doing be like garbage monster
version of this pull up hair to straight
up beyond us tell you what this look
won't make you do fall asleep it's a
good one
I'm just becoming actually a
stay-at-home dad what my personality is
just slowly morphing into I don't hate
it I make a lot of spaghetti these days
2017 worse things are happening Billy
Bobby Brown you always look so cool all
the time you look like a tiny viewer it
is not what I would expect against 13
year old to ever put on but you look
cool you look like if Big Bird got a
wish from Zoltar and his wish was to be
like a cool teenage female actress with
some wider emotional range than I'll
ever accomplish in my life this is it
awesome available to pitch that movie in
a very serious way I am so able to play
Big Bird if necessary I play it almost
every day of my life you know Rita Ora
oh girl this is sexy and fun you're just
like sexy you leave the Frank folder so
cute Bella Thorne why the nah this is
like Avril Lavigne a lot a lot of Avril
Lavigne Ivor Levine on Avril Lavigne on
that really long house is like matrix
Avril Lavigne this is like Ariel The
Little Mermaid is going through a
rebellious teen phase like she'll smoke
a cigarette and then get really
hedid and pretend she loved it but
really just actually nauseous and
everyone do again cute Lucy Hale is an
adorable AI robot she looks for cute and
like she's straight out of the forever
21 in Westworld it is fun I like this
outfit
you look very pensive it might have
caught you in a moment when your
interior programming was rebooting but
still very cute Vanessa Hudgens oh girl
I don't even know what era this is this
is like every era thrown into one but I
can't stop staring at your Barbie crotch
that's so perverted and gross mistake
it's just a fly top it don't see these
things like glam and luxurious and like
you might be throwing key parties later
what stop saying this stuff Victoria
Justice it was like you were at like a
bachelorette party and they played that
game where they had to make your wedding
dress at the toilet paper but you were
like 2017 they're wearing pantsuits
to my wedding and so they made you a
pantsuit I chose paper with the notion
and writing it for the Teen Choice
Awards this works let's go Maddie
Ziegler why does everyone look so cool
and sophisticated and there's young what
is it it's like you took drapes from a
very royal Asian household and you made
them into this cool two-piece yeah you
guys are so much cooler than Patrick
Starr
oh my god I love everything about it
what time is it hammer time because you
nail that this is awesome I have to stop
staring because it's very entrancing
grace Vanderwall oh my god you look so
cool a two-piece pink businesswoman
pantsuit I've never held a blazer over
my shoulder my entire life you just look
cool you look like like the expert as
like a young girl that's a compliment
that's supposed to be a compliment
that's very cool I think he dresses very
cool Oh Chloe Kendall Kalani and neo
from dance mom what I thought this was
fit harmony at first but it's not why do
all these young people look so good it
is stressing me out there's a very Spice
Girls 2.0 and I'm here for it because I
go ah yes good job there's good harmony
see you can see how I would think that
they look similar except
harmony looks like they're having a
little bit less fun what they smolder
harder but I like this you all well with
solid colors similar shapes but not
identical we got some tapes happening we
got some white pants happening because
if you all kind of decided on the same
thing but none of you wanted to back
down so you're like we just got a space
out how we stand together cute
teamwork GG gorgeous gg gg gg
I'm malfunctioning Jesus you gorgeous I
don't even know how to describe this but
this is adorable what is this this is
like you took a napkin from a fancy
restaurant and you just tied it around
the neck you're like I got this and you
know what you do got it
Mary Markson from clever you look good
girl what just a denim and lace jumpsuit
romper with light blue hair what how
dare you how dare you and also how dare
you Colleen ballinger girl you look King
fantastic everyone looks good it's
getting me excited and angry at the same
time ah Johnson David another clever TV
girl looking adorable watch where you're
walking girl but you got a snake skin
juice next day I'm just so happy that
Internet is there being so beautiful
some of us are at home experiencing
beauty in our own way Jake Paul they're
peeing Jake Paul this looks like Jake
fall we gotta find you a good tailor
because your knees are so strong your
butts on every pair of pants I've ever
seen you are well there you go that is
my review of the Teen Choice Awards I
know I missed a ton of people that you
probably wanted me to talk about but let
me know who you thought looks great and
who you thought looks like you know I
don't know subscribe to the future
channels you haven't already I make
videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes
[Music]